Matthieu the answer is yes and no first
of all Albert Einstein hated quantum
entanglement
he called it spooky added this spooky
action at a distance he couldn't get his
head around it but hey Einstein was
wrong we do this every day in the
laboratory and here's how it works
let's say we take two electrons very
close together and they vibrate in
unison everything vibrates two particles
together vibrate in unison now separate
them as you separate these two coherent
particles an umbilical cord
an invisible umbilical cord starts to
develop between these two particles such
that if you wiggle one particle then the
other particle is aware of the fact that
its partner is being wiggled so far so
good right but now separate these
particles by the distance of the Galaxy
itself so here are one end of the galaxy
we wiggle an electron and on the other
side of the galaxy
a hundred thousand light years distance
instantly faster than the speed of light
the other particle is aware of the fact
that is twin is wiggling now Einstein
said this is ridiculous because nothing
could go faster than the speed of light
but this effect has been measured
however you raise an interesting
question can you send a message this way
and the answer is probably no you see
the information traveling from one
electron to the other electron faster
than the speed of light on the other
side of the galaxy is random information
it's not Morse code you can't send a
love letter from one part of the
universe to another part of the universe
faster than the speed of light because a
love letter has net information
so in some sense maybe Einstein has the
last laugh it does mean that we have to
revise the famous statement nothing can
go faster than the speed of light now
what we have to say is no usable
information can travel faster than the
speed of light so in some sense
Einstein still has the last laugh